hello everyone and welcome to around
five of the 2018 bill chess festival
round four saw all of the games drawn
and Nicko here got his first to draw the
tournament after three losses and he
drew against none other than Magnus
Carlsen it was a it was a fantastic game
Nico had a better position but in the
end it was actually cousin who had to
fight for a draw and he was able to do
it so here after you know finally
breaking the losing streak he faces a
Maxine for Sheila gruff with the black
pieces though so we didn't have a photo
challenge for quite a while so I thought
we'd do one this video so best of luck
to everyone who is this chess player
here and since most of my audience is
from the United States this one will be
a piece of cake for you so there we have
it best of luck to everyone and we do
have a photo of this encounter there you
have it
Maxime on the left and Eko on the right
the photo was taken from Simon Bowen
boost it's it's an official photo from
the bill chess festival website which
I'll link to that will be in the
description below if you want to check
out some more photos there are quite a
lot of them and you know they are quite
lovely so let's check out the game we
have C 4 by Maxine so the Frenchman goes
for the English Knight to f6 William
Knight to c3 e 6 e 4 we have the
mechanics cross variation and now D 5
and here what has a couple of a couple
of options you can capture with the C
pawn you can capture with the e pawn you
can advance your upon which is what
Maxime does here he five and now comes
d4 the best reply pawn captures Knight
pawn captures knight on c3 and now B
captures on c3 it's a it's a better move
than doing something like F captures on
g7 after C capture some d2 with check
Bishop captures Bishop captures black it
is much more active here so after D
captures on c3 we'd have B captors on c3
Queen captures on f6 and now comes
Knight to f3 also possible it is d4 but
after that black will counter the Sentry
immediately with c5 and probably both of
them know this line all too well so
seem decides to go for a different one
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and now d4 as
the knight is no development c6 blocking
the sefa the C pawn from coming to c5 we
have E 5 opening up the center which may
seem like you know harsh decisions since
the black ink is in the middle of the
board but the White King is also in the
middle of the board and here while you
could capture on e5
for example D captures and in fact this
would actually give black very active
play as now the Queen is eyeing the G to
pawn not allowing the bishop to be
developed so well the white would need
to spend more time to finish development
so instead the Maxime gets a very nice
idea here instead of capturing the pawn
he gives up a pawn he plays Bishop to e2
I was black the capture on d4 we have
phone captures on d4 and now he doesn't
even bother to recapture rather he cast
first Bishop to g5 attacks the Queen
Queen to g6 and the now comes castles so
it doesn't matter to recapture the pawn
allows black to capture here with D
captures on c3 but you're not getting in
you know anything here you're just gonna
lose time and your king is still in the
center so we have Bishop to e7
continuing development Bishop to d3 now
attacking the Queen and although now you
could use this opportunity to develop
another piece and block the attack on
your Queen instead of Queen to d6
displayed
we have Bishop captures Knight captures
and only now C capture Sundy for
grabbing the pawn back where Nico
castles and we have rook to e1 so if you
look at this position black does have a
slightly better pawn structure even
though all of his bones are still you
know one starting point but he does have
two points White has three point islands
but maxime species are much more active
and this will prove sufficient as
compensation b6 preparing to develop the
light square bishop and here a very nice
move by Maxime
not allowing black to continue his
development immediately pushing c5 and
now it seems like he's offering he's
offering a free pawn here but in fact
he's not after captures captures and
captures the Queen still has to keep an
eye on the night and
seven after loop to see one the queen is
under attack and after you move the
Queen Queen d6 the only square you know
I'm good enough to defend this Knight
then you get Bishop captures on h7 King
captures Queen captures here pawn
captures and after row captures here
it's actually white who would have a
better pawn structure even though
material would still be equal maxine
would have a much better position to
point islands now against three point
islands and you know rooks really love
them
lonely lonely pawns so after c5 Queen to
f6 he doesn't bother capturing Bishop
the e4 now attacking the rook and on a
eight c6 blocking C captures a captures
and now just to check you know how how
you're doing feel free to pause the
video here and find it the strongest
move in the position it's a very nice
move a move that wins a pawn so you know
your spidey senses always need to be
tingling I will give it a couple of
seconds if you want to decide whether to
do it for those of you who were able to
do and congratulations you are an
excellent player a queen to b1 is the
move as you can see now both Queen and
the Bishop are attacking the h7 point
and the Queen is also attacking the b6
point so there is no way to defend both
threats Bishop to a5 blocking the attack
against the h7 pawn and now Maxine
captures the pawn queen capture some b6
and now by capturing on b6 he has
created a nice past a pawn Bishop
captures route captures and now comes
Queen to d6 Queen to c5 immediately
forcing a trade of Queens as the Queen
cannot move both Queen and rook would be
attacking the knight and e7 so Queen
captures pawn captures and now comes
Knight to d5
how will it be possible for Maxime to
take advantage of this extra pawn and
maybe push for something more than a
draw let's check it out
what does Maxime do well he does have a
passed pawn so he pushes it pawn to a4
g6 Nico creates some breathing room for
the kingdom oxime does so as well
rook F to be eight and then now comes
rook to c4 rook to c4 it's a wonderful
square for the rook from c4 okay it does
seem like it's not very active but
the rook will be guarding the c-54 NDA
for pawn so now this rook can become
active and another thing from c4
there's no really good there are no good
squares for Knight to attack the look
III is impossible b6 is impossible to do
the c5 pawn so a very nice square for
the rook rook to a6
we have 9th to d4 but the okayed
opponent c6 is already guarded rook to
b2 and the now comes rook to a3 we have
team to g7 improving the position of the
King rook to d3 and now preparing moves
like Knight captures here then the
knight would no longer be defended so
nicely 7 we have Knight to f3 and now
comes Knight back to d5 here Maxime
doesn't repeat it rather he goes Knight
to e5 or any v square is better than a
d4 square looked up before offering a
trade of rooks and now we have rook
captures Knight captures and rook to d7
attacking the f7 pawn there is no way to
defend it so first the King to g7 not
allowing it to come with check
we have Knight captures on f7 and here
although black can capture on a4 for
example row characters here but even
then white would simply continue in IG 5
attack the h7 pawn after h6 Knight back
to f7 attacking the h6 pawn now after
you push it Knight comes to d8 now there
will be an attack against the the c6
pawn the rook can also come help here
with with a double attack
so after Knight captures on f7 we have
worked to a5 Nico doesn't want to
capture Leah for pawn he wants to
capture the c5 pawn and create a passed
pawn of his own
we have 9th to g5 threatening to capture
on h7 and now well now is the critical
moment in the game feel free to pause
the video here and you know tell me can
Nico capture the c5 pawn so I will give
it a couple of seconds if you want to
just you know decide what we want to do
it for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations your spidey sense is
tingling excellently you know you can go
fight crime and for those of you who
said yes then you know that's you you
still have some work to do
rook captures on c5 doesn't work but
Annie
called it plate in the game it loses to
a very simple variation of course now
you're not gonna capture the point with
the rook as your knight is hanging and
the you're not even gonna capture with
the night rather you're just gonna give
a little check here and after this check
it was actually in this position that an
eco girl goddess resigned in the game
actually resigned because the only
available square for the king is g7 and
after g7 Knight to e6 check simply wins
the whole rook came to f6 doesn't really
matter where the King goes Knight
captures and now it's it's all over
black has no compensation it's
completely winning for white so that's
the game I mean it was winning even if
even if Nico didn't capture here on c5
better better is to capture on a4 but he
could have done that without even
preparing to capture on c5 but it's it's
winning for white either way so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you're enjoying the bill series
so far I would like to thank Mitchell
Weintraub and Mickey grammatical the
Jeff Fisher David Compton and time zone
plan for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and thank all for
watching and I will see you soon most
likely with another game from the bill
chest festival and we're gonna you know
check out some of some other photos and
the standings after round five and of
course we're continuing the facial
series thank you all and I'll see you
soon